[Music]
what's the deal with airplane penis
welcome to the fourth episode of the
joke world podcast uh today's guest live
from zoom our first zoom interview all
the way out in california we have joey
avery thank you for having me it's a
pleasure to be here and by here i mean
in my room but with you
yeah thank you for uh doing this such
short notice i hit you up last night and
we're recording the same day that that
your guys are going to see this on
youtube so the editing might be a little
quick but uh
so you're out in california so far we've
had some new york guides we've had some
austin guys um and we always kind of
touch on people different styles of of
comedy um and california is kind of the
third piece of that so you're in san
francisco correct i actually just moved
to l.a um but that is that is just out
of you know how comedians very often
you start somewhere you do it there for
a long time eventually you move to la
new york now austin um so i just came
down to to la but in terms of my style
definitely influenced by san francisco
and that's where i came up for most of
my years of of developing
so would you say um that this was
something that was written on the wall
all because you're close to
la or closer than you know me i grew up
in cleveland thinking about doing
standpoint maybe i'll go to l.a one day
milligan new york but you're kind of
close would would you say that this was
inevitable inevitable you were always
going to go to la and you finally made
the jump ah that's a
it's a really good question because
actually growing up in the san francisco
bay area um i've always had like an
antipathy towards la because we have
a rivalry so i've always been like oh
dude [ __ ] la i'm not going there
and uh in san francisco it's it's
actually kind of a like an actual city
so you can hop around do multiple shows
a night tons of stage time it's it's
almost more like the new york of the
west coast obviously on a much smaller
scale so a lot of me for the longest
time i thought i was gonna go to new
york just because i love being on stage
stand-up specific getting stage time
which is not what la is known for but uh
then you know my life happened and it
made more sense to move to la and a
bunch of my you know peers who i'd
started with in san francisco all also
moved to la and then it just became the
obvious choice because i had a lot of
things going on down here and it is
easier because i'm close to home and i
do love california um so so yeah so
that's why i ended up coming here
that makes sense as someone that doesn't
uh has never been there
but it hears a lot about it um is san
francisco as
crazy and
like absurd as people sound like i feel
like there can't be a place that
actually exists like this but the way
that you know rogan makes it sound and
what i'm hearing it's like i would i
want to stay as far away as i can
yeah no i that's a great question
because if you listen to like rogan or
if you read fox news articles everything
is like 12 people were shot by two gay
homeless people uh with heroin sticking
out of their ass while they were
[ __ ] on the street and like [ __ ]
a child and you're like oh my god i'm
never in a tent
yeah yeah exactly yeah and
so honestly like does san francisco have
its problems with homelessness things
that i would love if the city was able
to find a way to improve both for the
average citizen and homeless people
absolutely but the like fear-mongering
and everyone's saying it's just like war
zone like honestly those people are
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they don't know the
right places to go in san francisco san
francisco is the [ __ ] i stand by it it's
not as insane as you think but um it it
does suffer from the fact that downtown
like the main area if you don't know
where to go and you're just like
downtown it's kind of the worst part
but people who live there don't tend to
hang out in the tenderloin
uh as much even though there's a ton of
great comedy shows there but there's bad
parts of it i still it's great and
honestly if you know where to go it's
one of the most beautiful cities in the
country in the world
yeah that's there's bad parts about
every city but for some reason it seems
like san fran it makes you think you're
going to step off the plane and get
stabbed with fentanyl from some random
homeless dude like it's it's insane yeah
it's
the worst pr and that might be the worst
pr out of any any city in the country it
it's because its problems are are also
like aligned with super left-wing
politics so like it's got a bunch of
issues and it likes to fly the flag for
a bunch of things that
if you want to fight against it it's
like a poster boy for
where all these problems come from um
but yeah it used to be uh you know
people say there was it's worse than it
was a few years ago but if you talk
about what san francisco was like in the
80s or 90s like it was like a true war
zone and now there's a ton of like great
spots i don't know
yeah that i mean i've only really
thought of
of san francisco for their teams
obviously when they're playing one of
mine are you a uh
a warriors niners what is it probably
sharks yeah i mean you're just you're
speaking to me right now uh yeah
dubs niners giants sharks uh that's the
squad right there i've got a hat for
every one of them like sitting just to
my left okay yeah i don't think i have
any issues with any of those except for
uh the i hate i hate the warriors i'm i
was i moved to tampa a year ago i'm from
cleveland so
i'm a cavs fan and um actually now i
guess i don't really mind them but like
when we were in that four year stretch
of what was becoming maybe the greatest
rivalry in sports until kevin durant's
[ __ ] ass ruined it
i hated hated the warriors dude like
i don't know that that three 2016 is is
i'll always remember that the three one
i i was i was
dude i mean i didn't even like now i
don't mind stuff but back in the day
when he was throwing his mouth guard at
her fans and his wife's tweeting that
it's rigged and like those are the glory
days of the rivalry i hated him now i
can kind of appreciate how great he is
but back back in the day i was tweeting
things like ray allen is will forever be
the best three-point shooter this
stuff's like insulting
yeah just the [ __ ] that makes no sense
but i'm just like draymond purposely
kicks people in the balls it's not a
basketball move stuff like that but now
i can kind of appreciate it more yeah i
mean we can we could go on about this
because if draymond didn't get uh
suspended which i don't believe should
have happened uh katie never joins the
dubs it would have been a yeah a crazy
it is funny kevin durant made the
warriors so unlikable that now that he's
gone people are realizing that they are
like a really fun likable team again
without him yeah and honestly
i appreciate what he was able to do uh
for the city helped us win some
championships but i hope the nets fail
and he's a [ __ ] also
and also
how this is the funniest thing i love
how you're from [ __ ] cleveland and
you're like so san francisco sucks right
i know i know well i'm i'm in sunny
tampa now so i'm just i'm forgetting
about that
no it's uh the slanderer dude that's
that's a great point i'm [ __ ] sick of
the san francisco slander all right most
so many i'm in la it has just as bad of
a [ __ ] homeless problem as san
francisco but it doesn't get hit with
the same yeah i was gonna ask because
that's that's almost the same people are
[ __ ] on la a lot now have you even
noticed much of a difference or how has
the uh how's the move been yeah the
moves but the move's been good i think
the i i said this on stage a couple
times but basically like i think la's
homeless problem is just as bad as san
francisco's but no one here walks like
that's just the difference because
everyone's in a car so you just drive by
people like you don't think about the
fact that they're [ __ ] on the street
because you're not even on the sidewalk
you know but it's it's pretty nice it's
pretty bad uh here and uh i don't know
exactly how to
solve it but uh you know it's tough
yeah um well if you ever do figure out
how to solve how solve it let us know
[ __ ] comedy if i could we gotta solve it
i would i'd be doing that yeah we gotta
get to the bottom of that that's funny
yeah so uh
you know the big move and then you're on
you're on the road a lot you said i just
missed you uh were you at side splitters
over here i actually did uh i did three
daughters brewing
um okay brewery and saint pete it was
their first ever comedy show actually um
so they flew me out to come headline and
i did coastal creative um which was
right next door in
saint pete through don't tell comedy but
i think they do a lot of side splitter
stuff
at coastal creative too so it was it was
all in st pete but it was really fun
okay yeah it's a good scene around here
because um it's not like coming up it's
not weird to drive a little bit for
stage time if you can find it and having
being in tampa then also having the
tampa bay region like st p and all that
stuff within 20 30 minute drive um there
it's it's a good little scene down here
you can definitely find it's definitely
better than cleveland seen um just a
bigger city i guess but
yeah have you performed in cleveland no
i haven't um i'm sure i will soon and i
i do look forward to it um
i find that places that are off the
beaten path not the cleveland's the
boondocks but it's not like a top four
u.s city i feel like those places are
always really fun crowds because people
are fired up you're there you know and
like it's uh yeah yeah it's always a
good it's interesting about tampa so one
thing i always loved about coming up in
san francisco is you have the city and
then you go across the bridge and then
you have oakland so you basically have
multiple different scenes tampa it
sounds like has that with you've got
tampa then you have saint pete and
they're all i think it's many obviously
in different scales but it's all
miniature versions of what works so well
in new york which is like you have the
whole scene in manhattan and then you've
got you cross the bridge and then you've
got brooklyn you've got a totally
different ecosystem you know different
politics people have different views
yeah
exactly yeah yeah that's a good way to
set up comedy uh in cleveland it was
hilarities is the is the
the premier club then there was
there was an improv there but no one
really goes there was pretty sketchy it
was
no one really goes there and then it was
just like
a few bars that would have weakly open
mics but they're all on the same street
and they're all just like in a actual
bar like they're just the main comedy
club but then it's just like bar time
so it is nice because going i don't know
if the bridge is maybe a metaphor or
like a literal thing because saint pete
and all this stuff but going over the
bridge and like finding like um a new
group in a new area but still having
access to those stages but they have
they think differently their life is a
little different
i think that can just kind of round you
out maybe as a comic
yeah you want a place that will push you
into different types of comedy so it can
function as like a microcosm of you know
the country
or you know i guess the world but
essentially that's what you want is to
be able to if you can figure out or if
you have to learn how to kill at an open
mic a comedy club and a bar in a super
liberal part of town a more open-minded
part of town a conservative if you have
access to all those things um it'll just
make you a better comic and in the bay
area you'd have i mentioned san
francisco and oakland but there's also
tons of like you know you've got super
city rooms and then you go outside of it
just a little bit and you can be in the
santa cruz mountains where people are
uh it feels a lot more like the middle
of the country right you're in like an
old bike yeah yeah and people have you
know they don't want to hear your uh
your
city manicured set so
right that's all super valuable
so
that is kind of how it has always been
coming uh how since comedy started
people going on the road having to you
know tailor different audiences but now
with um comedians constantly uploading
clips burning material or crowd work
which you do a lot of and we i'd like to
talk about that later but
that seems like you can get the whole
countries are or a bunch of different
pools or a bunch of different um
viewpoints all those people are seeing
you know the same clip it's it's almost
like being in a room with the whole
internet at once do you find that you
can kind of uh fast fast forward through
that process of maybe working out
different material in different rooms
because the internet is such a big test
build or do you do you ever worry about
putting up certain clips for an
offending certain audience or maybe not
offending but you know just being like
people saying [ __ ] if it's a political
joke or something like how is the
internet and opening up your room to not
just the people there watching your
stand up but to everyone how has that
kind of kind of changed things
that's a very complex uh
question because i think the results of
that we're kind of in a test tube for
right now
um i think where it will probably push
comedy is actually the opposite
direction
because i think uh even though you get
exposed to more people
and you might get a bunch of hate and a
bunch of love all in the same thing and
you get to see where people are coming
from i think the internet tends to push
people more towards
a hyper-pleasing one specific group
and then
uh and that's when you really go viral
so like i post a lot of crowdwork stuff
because i am trying
maybe this is a still an old-school
perspective but i'm trying not to burn a
ton of my material i like crowd work and
those are one-off moments i'm like
that'll never happen again [ __ ] throw
it out there so if you just watch my
[ __ ] online you think i'm a crowdwork
comic not the case it just happens to be
what i post
um i also have stuff coming like i saved
my material for i'm doing something on
comedy central like that all right now
i'll give you my jokes i'm not just
gonna go [ __ ] around yeah for that
um but like one of my most successful
jokes that i've posted recently on tick
tock was
a pretty it was a joke but it was a
pretty straightforward opinion that
really only pleased one side of the
abortion debate and that went super
viral because people can argue about it
on there and then it gets more
so like unfortunately i think that you
you think the internet oh you have
access to everyone it'll it'll bring
people together it'll make your comedy
have to stand the test of pleasing
everyone for some people that's true but
i think for a lot of people they're
going to realize that they get most of
their love when they
stick to one side and
please them and incite debates online
and watch their views go up while
they've set fire to the comment section
which is not a good thing but yeah
people respond to strategy i think
that's what's gonna happen
that's that's and that's like how
facebook's whole algorithm was showing
you stuff that you disagree with because
you're gonna comment more then you're
getting fights and the comments will
drive up the algorithm
i don't know if that's a
yeah maybe you post controversial [ __ ]
just so you know that people will fight
in the car yeah that's just so
interesting yeah it's it's tough i mean
like i i guess maybe one potentially
positive angle you could take that is
your stuff will resonate if it's good if
it's funny but the thing that i've been
learning is it's not just about being
good and funny it's like does it make
people feel some type of way
and right you don't necessarily have to
do that in a shitty or a political way
you can do that and it's super relatable
or it's shining light on a feeling that
they feel like hasn't been expressed i i
don't happen to go to therapy but i see
therapy [ __ ] does insanely well on tick
tock so it's not all just politics but
like can
your joke be funny uh you know well
structured but can it also make people
like feel something i think that's yeah
another angle
that's definitely
something that i feel like people would
would be seeking um in the in the room
and on the apps is some relatability
but you mentioned the thing about if
some people might think you're just a
crowd work comic if they saw your social
media that's how i first saw you was
just a really funny crowd work um
uh reel i think on instagram and um
that's so weird because i feel like
crowd work everyone wants to burn it or
upload crowd work because it's not
burning any material because it's like
not necessarily prepared or yeah it will
never happen again like you said but
also there's something about the
authenticity of crowd work it's the same
reason that podcast clips i think go
viral more than written stand up clips
nowadays is because you know that that
wasn't written you know that that just
happened in the moment and for people in
the audience it's i mean there's there's
tricks and there's t and there's things
that you can do to get good at crowd
work but for the average person in the
audience like it's
so impressive and it almost feels like a
magic trick to watch you like learn
someone's job and then as they're saying
it already have a joke about that job
coming back at them or the city that
they're from or like a weird developing
situation in the crowd that you're going
back like those clips just are more
enjoyable i think for
online than a a setup and a punch
yeah i think you're totally right
there's something about you too that
that just jumps off the screen because
like like you said there are tricks for
crowd work i personally
maybe someone can correct me if i'm
wrong i don't think i'm using any of
them like i think my best moments are
something just happens and in the moment
i just like feel something and there's
like a little extra twinkle in your eye
when something clicks and i'm
ex i'm experiencing a joke for the first
time
just as the person in the audience is
just as the person on the phone is like
we're truly sharing this moment whereas
well-written stand-up is i think it's a
higher art form it's more interesting
especially if you're sitting for an hour
you want to know what someone thinks
about something that they've worked on
that's been tested
and it's you know
hopefully you're giving someone
something more thoughtful with that
but um yeah with crowdwork it's just
like whoa what's happening it is an
authentic moment and i think um
authenticity will always win online um
beyond anything else like and if you can
just live like i honestly think about
that it almost makes it seem like like
these days you need to actually be
almost an authentic person like through
and through your life or else the
internet will find out about something
that you've done or lied about and then
[ __ ] hate you and tear you apart no
matter what like i feel like you need to
be authentic on screen and in your life
all the time now
yeah that's that's a good point do you
remember the first time you
you ever did crowd work because i assume
the first i mean very first few times
going up you definitely
had some things written that you were
going to say because it's very
nerve-racking getting up for the first
few times and crowd work as a beginner
comic seems
so intimidating because the number one
thing is i don't wanna have nothing to
say you know it's almost
it's almost like like a pot like doing a
podcast for the first time it's with
someone that you just met like right now
it's like all i want is that we get
through this it's fun and that there's
no time where for two minutes i wasn't
just sitting here blushing like i have
nothing to say i mean you know so like
do you remember the first time ever
trying crowd work
dude i actually don't because i don't
remember ever trying to do it like it
was always just oh okay a react it was
always a reactive thing so i think it
was it was mostly like doing shitty
shows and then
being halfway through this like really
long pedantic overwritten bit and just
like [ __ ] panicking and being like
this is not gonna work and then just
like having to be like what the [ __ ] is
going on with you or like someone drops
a glass in the audience and i'm like oh
thank god i have something to react it
was always like more reactive than
trying to go out and seek it out
yeah that makes sense there's definitely
a fine line between
reacting and starting
talking a conversation with someone in
the crowd and then a heckler handling a
heckler have you had any of those
moments and have any of those increased
because people see you online and they
think oh he enjoys fan interaction this
is this guy he'll let me say some stuff
in the audience
yeah i
i don't think i'm big enough yet that
people have like bought tickets to come
[ __ ] with the shows and and so hopefully
that doesn't happen because uh like i
said i i really um
you know i i'd like it to be reactive
and natural
um but that is something that can happen
i i talked to um so andrew schultz did a
a crowdwork special and i was doing
shows with him pretty soon after he did
that and he basically was like oh i need
to actually stop doing crowd work for
several shows because
i've i've over indexed the audience
towards that and i want to bring them
back into knowing that i do material so
you do really have to be careful yeah
about like training and managing
people's expectations
um but i haven't had too many issues
with it there's a phrase that is
was passed down i don't remember where i
heard it i certainly didn't come up with
it but it's kind of a comedic maxim with
hecklers
which is if someone's really
disrupting the show like you want to
give them enough rope to hang themself
is the phrase that makes sense and it's
basically like let them be annoying
before you jump down their throat
there's way too many comics who've been
told oh i can just [ __ ] on a heckler and
so the second somebody does like even
well-intentioned does something out of
school they're like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you i'm gonna [ __ ] your mom
and you're like oh my god yeah yeah yeah
um yeah
and because a lot like that's that's
i'll see a lot of sets where someone
will yell something out
real quick and they're obviously trying
to get involved and it's not even rude
and the comedian will just move right
past and pretend like they never heard
it because they're just in the middle of
their show and it didn't disrupt
anything and it was obviously someone
just trying to be like
i'm adding in the show and they'll yell
out some [ __ ] like yeah like a celebrity
name pete davidson and they're like i
just
keep going i really think most people
are incredibly well intentioned although
probably also incredibly drunk and so
like the first like i really try and
like instruct people and let people know
like hey like don't do like it'll you
know these things will happen naturally
like don't you know push out or i'll
just like you know dismiss them and and
try and quit on them real quick but
sometimes it gets out of hand but
it's very rarely is it done with any
malicious intent and i think that's
important to keep in mind because like
at the end of the day if you're doing
stand-up you're kind of throwing the
party for everyone there
and so you want to make it fun for
everybody and if someone's out of hand
you want to have a light touch i feel
like
yeah um real quick it's like a party
that yeah sorry just to interrupt you
real quick i have this weird thing where
my computer is like forcing me to shut
down in like two minutes and i see we
have seven minutes on the zoom do you
want to just pause and hop back on
yeah because i was going to say i was
going to wait for it to dwindle down
i didn't know that you could see that i
was going to wait for that to dwindle
down and then tell you and be like i'm
not going to pay for this one so let's
hop back on and off but i'm glad that
you said that let's uh let's take a
quick break
yeah we'll hop back on yeah my computer
thing hopped up too so it's perfect
all right we're back
it saved me like seven dollars i think
[Laughter]
yeah that's great let me get these back
going
my headphones so i don't bleed over all
right we're back after the technical
difficulties or whatever you want to
call
yeah extreme couponing and uh
so you mentioned uh working a little bit
with andrew schultz uh beforehand and
that's uh definitely something that you
know is our i know my subscribers uh
enjoy his podcast flagrant too and and
he's in a good amount of our edits um
i'm assumed that they would like to hear
about what it's kind of like maybe
behind the scenes touring um pre-show
green room uh
that kind of and that's a super broad
question but um
uh no i think it's actually i think it's
an instructive question because i've
definitely you know the cool thing about
getting to work with
any of the comics who i've gotten to
work with who are further along is you
you get to learn
you know maybe what makes them what sets
them apart from the average people that
you're working with and uh
so to give you the green room with
schultz before shows uh i'll say this he
does not touch booze before he goes on
stage
at all it's super dialed in
afterwards sometimes yes sometimes no we
definitely have fun it can be a really
great time but before shows he's always
locked in um
you know he'll and also like he'll help
like we've had joke riding sessions
before shows where he'll basically say i
you know this this flip isn't working
right like what might help here um yeah
you can throw out ideas that you have
and be like is this getting there and
he'll help you so it's pretty business
oriented um unless there's like a ufc on
then it's very focused on that
that's pretty good that's pretty cool
actually and that's kind of
how i might have imagined it i feel like
the more you hear about the real details
of people they're demeanor before shows
how they approach the stage um as a fan
you just think they're up there they're
having fun they're having a good time
what but the more that i hear about how
people approach these shows it's so
business like even like bert i've heard
him say so many times he doesn't drink
before during shows then he'll go back
on and be like
i don't think that's true i think yeah i
haven't seen it but i'm pretty sure he
opens his set by shotguning a beer
yeah he'll say that then he'll be like
i'll have him bring me a water with a
lime so it looks like i'm drinking or
i'll have one on the last he goes but
it's just the fact that he even pretends
like he doesn't drink during the show i
feel like more people handle it this is
flinging around i feel like more people
handle it um in a business-like manner
than i still have wires on my headphones
it's 20 22. that's my fault it's like
people how's san francisco
um
i think there's a there definitely was a
phase of comedy where it was dominated
by people who would rack up lines of
coke and get hammered and just let it
fly out there um i think that's harder
to do now just because it's so
competitive and i don't know i think
society has like listen i got no problem
with doing drugs and partying but um i
think just society's attitude towards uh
mental health uh in terms of doing that
[ __ ] all the time at your job has
probably shifted a little bit at your
job
but the funny thing is so the funny
thing is you know sometimes being really
business like before the show
is what allows you to truly be having
fun and relaxed and kind of
almost partying during the show and not
to say that that means you're like
[ __ ] up but just like a lot of times
i've found the more times i've prepared
i'm like truly ready for the show
then you can really get out there and be
like all right i've done everything i'm
just gonna let myself be free and yeah
it's all gonna work out and so um you
know being business-like is not at odds
with uh being carefree on stage right
yeah and it feels it's more fun it's
less it's more relaxing and way less
stressful to go
because getting on stage in itself is
like a
it's it's a thing that you have to do it
i mean it i'm sure the stress gets
relieved by the the bigger stages or it
may not stress but nerves but ultimate
preparation is something that can
relieve all of that so then you go up
there knowing you're gonna kill and
knowing that can make it so much more
fun because you're like i'm so prepared
i know what i'm saying i know if this
and that and and everything else but you
know just being like kind of carefree or
[ __ ] up before the show and not
knowing what's gonna happen on stage
seems a lot more stressful than being
dialed in and being like i know this is
gonna be great and i'm gonna have fun
after yeah i'll give you two i'll give
you two things on that the first is is a
jordan quote i read when i was young
which is basically that where he said
that like
he doesn't get nervous when he takes
free throws because he knows he put
everything into it that he possibly
could in practice or so whenever a big
moment comes he's like the ball may or
may not go in but i know that i did
everything to make sure it could go in
so what the [ __ ] is there to be nervous
about because i didn't [ __ ] up like i
did everything yeah so exactly and he's
and that's from the second best
basketball player of all time oh my god
get the [ __ ] out of here that is insane
that's not insane i have a bias let me
live
you're you're an la guy huh you like the
l.a lebron
that's different let me give you the
flip side of that though which is like a
ton of the like look i
s some of the best crowd work clips that
you've seen of mine uh on instagram i've
been like
pretty drunk for not like a lot but just
like there are a few times where i've
had
an event all day and i'm like well i'm
gonna pick up a show that night and then
i go and i'm like well i'm too drunk to
do my material so let's just [ __ ] around
with people and yeah something amazing
happens so yeah it's really like you got
to figure out what works for you i don't
like being
uh drunk on stage but i absolutely have
done it and can do it and sometimes it's
great it's not better i wouldn't do it
if i was headlining uh an important show
you're right
it's kind of fun sometimes you have a
few yeah you know a few drinks you're a
little more loose you you experiment
more you go into the crowd like it can
it can help a hundred percent
and people
sometimes like that you're drinking
because they're drinking and it's like i
don't know i one of the things that made
me like comedy so much growing up is
like i like that that everyone seems
like they're getting after it like it's
a it's a party i don't know if you saw
the uh comedy store documentary but back
in the in the day when they were going
through all those dudes like the
kinnison and all those guys like that
was [ __ ] absurd like i was like yeah
totally and i'm like absolutely a party
guy like i
love doing it i was like there have been
times where i've been bummed like i
thought comics would party more you know
but the older i get the more i'm like
okay it's a balance like
sometimes it is party time and sometimes
it's very much work time and you know
make sure that you're healthy and like
everything's a balance and everyone's
balance is different
but um you know i i really like being
around comics that push me to
focus more and be more business-like
yeah but i very much get along with
comics who are like let's [ __ ] party
and i'm like let's go yeah yeah
yeah
that's awesome i feel like uh the crowd
work with with a little buzz going you
know just wet the whistle a little bit i
feel like that might be a little easier
i don't know
like that christos stefano 911 story
he's hammered he keeps every every like
three words he's like i'm drunk let's
keep going it's like this is funny like
there is magic there is magic to be
found there but you don't want to make
it your thing because it's you can't
like bottle it you can't do it all the
time yeah if you're drunk all the time
comic shit's gonna get dark uh but yeah
you know and it's funnier when it's
unexpected or like yeah yeah because if
you were like
i don't think it's as funny as people
expect it to be if you were expecting
someone to be drunk and then you went
and saw them and they're just like kind
of drunk and talking and being like this
is this kind of weird but if you did if
you were just at a show with a random
lineup and one guy was just had
different energy and he's buzzing a
little bit it's like all right this is
this is fun but i don't think it'd be
that funny to watch like a hammered guy
just talk for
no no not for like a 45-minute set and
that's the thing is people always are
like
people just a lot of people have
even as big as comedy and podcasts and
all of this world is there are a lot of
people that go to shows and just have no
[ __ ] clue what's going on they'll
literally be like oh you guys are always
hammered right and i'm like what are you
talking about like yeah no it's a hard
you know it's a
there's a relative degree of difficulty
to what you're trying to do
being drunk doesn't necessarily help but
sometimes it does you know
yeah yeah and if anything it can kind of
help nerves or
or uh just maybe you'll say some things
that you might not have usually said so
this has been a lot of on stage content
but some of my favorite things that you
do
um are the little skits or just like uh
videos um that aren't obviously stamped
i guess they would be called skits but
sometimes skits just i hate that i hate
the word sketch and i hate
yeah
and i hate when like when like people
like my parents will call like um like
stand-up skits like on like actual
stand-up like your skit and i'm like
it's so funny people still use that word
especially in the era of stand-up
becoming like you know like i'd love for
someone to go up to
drew michael after he does like 20
minutes about being like horribly
depressed and like wanting to kill
himself and they're like what was that
skit you closed with yeah yeah yeah
exactly
yeah but it's a completely separate
thing and it i don't know i don't know
how people i don't know maybe it's just
people that aren't that close to stand
up it is it's just it's just ignorance
it's well-meaning but they just don't
know the right words
yeah so how would you go about making
your your cute little skits
versus your
so like like the sketch stuff that i do
yeah yeah
like i saw the um the
uh my
amazing interview prep was scrolling
through your instagram
and uh some that really made me laugh i
probably saw it when it was actually
posted but the uh listening to rogan
back in the day versus now and just like
because that's something that was so
relatable to me because i'm a fan and i
you know and it is
it was so much more carefree and like
and like oh this is some stuff this is
like not life hacks but it's like
and not bro science well maybe it was
bro science but exactly your sketch just
summed it up perfectly but like those
kind of those kind of clips like is it
more fun to write those you think than
stand up do you do it on a schedule or
is it if a sketch comes to me i'll film
that real quick
it's it's a little bit of both but it's
more it's more like an idea will come to
me like that actually hit me like it was
during one of like the crazy like covid
and i was listening to rogan but
everything was like super politicized
and it was just like it just seemed like
everyone who didn't even listen to it
had an opinion and so you were like yeah
you wouldn't want to get caught
listening so i was just driving down and
i was like listening and i was like oh
i'm on spotify which is public maybe i
should just go to like private session
real quick because who knows i don't
want to have the conversation then i was
like what the [ __ ] am i doing like the
fact that i'm going pri so it was really
just a moment that hit me so um
you know like i was talking about if if
your content online can make people feel
something uh i just try and think about
what i'm feeling and then like make it
and hope that it makes sense to people
yeah so uh with with you know an idea
will come to me and then usually i'll
just figure out oh that's probably more
of a sketch than a bit you know that's
probably yeah that makes sense for
example i actually riffed something on
stage that i had a clip of and i was
like you know what this would be better
as a sketch and then i just made that
sketch today because it was about like
instagram motivational speakers i was
like this will play more if i just do it
as a sketch so usually it's just what i
think is a better vehicle for the
thought that i had but at the same time
if i know i'm trying to get some videos
out a week and i don't have any stand-up
clips or i've been posting a ton of
crowd work clips and i want to mix it up
sometimes i'll like sit down and just be
like think like let's [ __ ] make
something to just because i i do want to
be able to i want to be known as a
stand-up first which is why i mostly
post stand-up stuff but i really want to
always push in different directions
because you really never know what's
going to hit on online and and i don't
want it right i want to have multiple
types of content for people isn't that
so funny that nowadays people have to be
like known as just such a like one thing
or the other because like
i feel like no one like like stand like
comedian stand-ups should be you know
people post shorts and like sketches and
like stuff like that all the time and
you would never say that someone on snl
is not a comedian but yet the internet's
just so like one thing or the other that
if you just started post if you posted
10 sketches in a row and then went back
to stand up people would be like you
know you're oh yeah what are you doing
oh you're on stage now like that's so
weird that you can't just be a funny
funny person you know yeah i mean i
guess you can but you can't yeah i mean
but so i've worked with with trevor
wallace and he's a very funny stand-up
but his dominant internet presence is uh
sketches like his stuff right dominates
youtube does super weird yeah perfect
example but but you know
his tour he's doing right now is called
the are you that guy tour because people
like they've seen him they don't know
where they've seen him they don't know
why they've seen him if they have seen
him a lot of them are shocked that he
actually does stand up even though he's
been doing stand-up the whole time guys
selling out [ __ ] theaters so like
it's just you do have to
and it even ties back into what we were
talking about earlier with if you just
do crowd work people will think you're
just a crowdwork person it makes sense
that's what they've seen so whatever
people know you from is
is what they're gonna people used to go
to chapelle's uh shows and just scream
i'm rick james [ __ ] and he's like a
brilliant stand-up yeah right so you do
have to you gotta lean into what works
and what you can put out there but you
do really need to be cognizant of okay
what type of um what type of audience do
i want to build what do i want them to
know me as
um so that you don't end up in kind of a
weird spot where you're trying to tell
people no this is actually my thing like
this is what i want you to know me for
that's because
yeah i guess it is just whatever you
represent yourself as it's not their
fault
like i just saw uh chad and jt at moon
power or moon moon tower comedy festival
in in austin and
um i had no idea what to expect of their
st i knew that they were stand-ups
because like i'm invested in this
community but like
the main thing i've seen from them are
sketches or like when they're at court
council
yeah yeah city council yeah you'd expect
to go advocate for a nickelback statue
or something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
then it's their job to say like how can
we take what you know us as and
shoehorn it into our stand-up and they
do a really good job because their
stand-up is
uh in the same mindset and character of
everything they're so kind of those
characters but it's still about their
actual life a little bit too they push
it a little further than the online
characters would so it's but yeah you do
have to
you have to be careful like you might
get pigeonholed into the wrong thing and
it's you know it's
kind of your fault i mean we're all just
trying to like
at the end of the day all this started
at least i speak for myself but i assume
the same for you is like all this
started as for me was like [ __ ] can i
avoid having a nine-to-five job here's
this thing that i love if i can ever
just do this i'll be the happiest guy in
the world so you do whatever works and
you don't look a gift horse in the mouth
but
you do really have to be careful about
what type of audience you build and even
with doing like really edgy like i don't
like to be filtered i like to make
[ __ ] up jokes i like to make political
jokes um i have a podcast called pier69
we you know we push it sometimes
and i think people get it but you even
have to be careful sometimes you make a
joke and you're like oh that's edgy and
then people are like yeah i love that
and you're like whoa yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was kidding and i feel like you
like it too much and it's weirding me
out that's funny that's like that's like
a big j uh ogresson joke he had a joke
where he's like it would be weird for me
if i was saying like
racist jokes and everyone in the crowd
wasn't laughing if they were just like
nodding their head like yep
i'd be like i'd be like what this is not
a political rally we're just like yeah
this comedy you're pushing on the edge
it's funny to say the wrong thing even
when you know it's wrong like
that's why it's and that's why it's
funny right and yeah that's like
like even in the so the last last
wednesday a week ago was the day after
this whole chapel thing happened i can't
believe it's only been a week because i
feel like we've heard about it so much
which is yeah maybe my fault too but
whatever uh and
and i was i did a solo podcast after
that one just talking about exactly that
incident and there was a comment that
and i i think i was joking i joked
around and said my only uh regret or my
only thing i wish was different is that
like they could have put them in maybe
like a one day coma like just a quick
coma that he doesn't die but just like
maybe it'd be more of a punishment for
like a quick coma
i had this long long paragraph about
from someone that was like i've watched
all your your compilations and your
edits and cut ups and stuff really like
this channel but like it just goes to
show like you never know so i can't
believe that you would say this and like
a camp like what's your character like
and like who are your morals one to two
day coma really like
i was like
obviously i don't i don't i don't know
this guy at all i the the situation
already happened i can't change any of
this i'm just so surprised that you that
on a channel called joke world that you
would take anything i say seriously
at all let alone like
something that i thought was pretty
extreme
to say yeah you get you're gonna get
shocking [ __ ] like you could say the
most obviously untrue
over the top joking that you could you
know you could be talking about cutting
off your own [ __ ] and then someone would
be like i can't believe you're trivial
trivializing people who've like chopped
off their own dicks yeah what are you
[ __ ] talking about so there's just
too many people out there
there are too many people i can end it
literally too but like people your
people will it'll catch it on a weird
day or whatever the [ __ ] and they'll
take it completely literally and so for
as long as your career lasts you're
gonna look at comments and be like what
in the living [ __ ] is this this makes no
sense but at the same time and i try not
to look at comments too much but
sometimes you'll read something and be
like maybe i misrepresented this or
maybe i didn't think about it that way
and so i don't know sometimes it's
sometimes you can learn something from
it you can even in that even in that
instance i kind of for a second felt bad
i was like oh i don't want anyone to
think
that i want but then i was like oh
i'm not advocating for violence yeah you
can go back and yeah this person they're
never going to be happy and you're going
to like neuter your entire joke and so
you just got to keep it moving but it's
a data point
yeah how do you go about um
keeping
keeping yourself grounded while also
pursuing internet uh maybe i don't know
fame internet fame or just you know you
want as many comments and likes and as
possible on your on your comedy material
and all this stuff but a certain point
then while the numbers go up it seems
like people just become numbers and you
become numb to just like this is a real
person saying this or is this just an
account i'm just looking at my phone
like
have you found that that you struggle to
keep like this in real life that like
even real people are commenting these
things because at certain point when
there's so many it just seems like
what even is this
that's a really good question i mean you
can't
if you took every single comment as like
uh
you know an expression of a human form
that's worthy of love and light and your
attention like you would blow your
brains out in like two weeks yeah
because like it's just there's too much
hate there's vitriol there's insanity
like good comments still like
yeah like i'll still get excited like oh
cool like people like this bad ones uh
i'll try and be like
i'll
i mean a lot of times i just brush it
off but sometimes i'll try and be like
is there something to it yes no if yes
my feelings are really hurt if no you're
[ __ ] you are a number you're an idiot
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah um
so you know it's it's tough you really
do have to at some point look at it
a little bit like a business and like
you you really are like especially with
all the analytics tools that are online
now like you really are aggregating your
numbers and and pitting them against
previous performance and like wondering
if you're doing growth which is the
appropriate mindset for growing a
business but
um
you know so i i guess
i guess i do really look at it
analytically um but where it becomes
real for me is like when enough people
follow me and then those people buy
tickets come to the shows interact with
me
and and are there for the right reasons
and like me like that's where the
humanity comes back in and it's like oh
this is awesome these people found me
they [ __ ] with me
um you know we're building something
together like i think that's the time to
to think about people as people and not
like if it's just some random person who
wasn't going to like you anyway talking
[ __ ] you know if p it's like the people
who want to comment negative [ __ ] on
your stuff were not going to be your fan
anyway so keep it moving
yeah there's no point of even
you know working yourself up about that
have you are you a um
a big comment deleter or no
uh
usually
usually no but like every once in a
while it's like i don't need it i don't
necessarily need this on my page like
i'm trying to get my page out in front
of people who are gonna like it so every
once in a while um if i see something i
really don't like or it's just not
necessary just yeah but i'll leave an
occasional comment but you don't want to
do too many of them one because then it
gives your fans not a chance to back you
up like if you leave one out there that
has 10 replies of people being like [ __ ]
off that makes you feel even better it
creates some camaraderie there but
there's some things that i just don't
want like the the other people to see
like if people that might not know me
yet or be on the border i don't want
this just to be something that enters
you know that's why i kind of want to
just clear them off not because it
necessarily hurt my feelings but i don't
want that to be like under this video
for new people's opinions to be formed
from yeah it's a business decision and
people online want to be like oh we
caught you you're cleaning up dude it's
business and and i think like you said
like if i have a funny clap back i'll do
it i usually don't i usually just don't
interact let other people handle it like
you said but yeah dude it's it's a
business there's this weird like gotcha
idea online of like you're deleting
comments yeah you're doing this or
you're doing that it's like trying to
grow a page man like i don't know what
to tell you like this is you know
yeah
i don't i'm doing my best i don't i
don't yeah i'm not gonna make everyone
happy like it's not possible especially
as a comedian you're gonna piss people
off it's probably a good thing if you
weren't then no one would like you but
like it's just i don't know
how do you go about um
and this might be one of my last
questions i feel like we're probably
reaching the the next 20 minutes but how
do you how do you go about uh
you know you're saying you're always
going to piss someone off if you're
doing something right so
in these rooms you know what you think
is funny is just funny however in the
last maybe four or five years it's been
kind of like
um your opinion people's opinions can
carry weight in in culture or cultural
value and opinions or like if you have
the wrong opinions you're worthless and
in comedy that's something that i feel
like good comedians have not given into
but um some have or some maybe have
online or on twitter just trying to
cover themselves that way how how have
you handled um
you know this hard time for right or
wrong opinions while also being someone
on stage that's supposed to say
controversial kind of things
i don't know i mean
it's
i think trying
i think
yeah all good
i think trying to
like
4d chess your way into like the right
strategic way to
please everybody with your opinion is
impossible so i really like
try not to overthink it i mean i really
what i try to do is like
just do what i think is funny and i
think the people that will find it will
find it and and the people that
that uh
will hate it we'll also probably find it
and then keep it moving which is fine
with me but like i i comedy is a hard
enough thing to do
i'm just trying to do it the only like
to the best of my abilities which is
unidirectional like i can only be the
most
joey averiest person that i can be i
don't know if i can strategically maybe
you decide ah we should cut that joke
that wasn't even a good representation
of me i stepped over the line whatever
but like
um
i i don't know how to strategically do
it i try to just be authentic and and
come from a good place and and at the
same time say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and push
the envelope and say stuff that would
work if i was talking to my friends
sitting around a campfire off a couple
of glasses of whiskey and uh not
everyone's gonna like that but hopefully
more do than don't and you know [ __ ] it
i don't know and that's perfect because
that's when
i mean i won't speak for you but i feel
like most people like that's when you
found out that you were or maybe not
found out but when you were funny or
when you're used to making people laugh
is like with your buddies at the lunch
table in the locker room around a fire
you know a little buzz going or just
whatever and and you're you're just
talking and you're saying whatever comes
to your mind you're not holding back
you're not worried about anything you're
not you know worried you know they're
your best friends and you're just being
[ __ ] hysterical and they're like dude
that's
you know running running a lunch table
can feel better than a whole open mic
sometimes or oh 100 yeah and that's like
that's i feel like what
what
my i mean from someone at a lower point
in this like trying i want to not just
say what i think is going to be funny i
want to be who i am like around my
friends when it's when it's really funny
not just like made up stories about like
this is my setup and this is my punch
line i want to be just like and i think
that crowd work gives you
that opportunity because that's what
that whole thing is is basically crowd
work
with your friends you know what i mean
it's reactionary it's conversational
humor
um and it can teach you how to write
like i think i made somewhat of a
breakthrough through doing crowdwork
because
it wasn't my like super particular uh
written following a certain path trying
to trying to
walk a line where i please everybody
because when i'm at home writing i am
thinking about everyone else and i don't
want to do anything that's going to piss
anybody off because i don't really want
to piss anybody off i just know what's
going to happen
um in crowd work it's just like
something happens boom you have to be
funny in that moment it's authentic
something happens and so
that can teach you how to even do that a
little bit more in your writing first
thing that came to you like when you're
writing and you actually make yourself
laugh you know you're in the car on the
way up the mic and you're thinking of
you're like oh that could work that
could work that could work and then one
thing pops you and you go oh [ __ ] yeah
like that
that's worth the shot and so
you're just you're gonna cross the line
because you're trying to to find it in a
way that works and and
it is sad that these days that can lead
to like uh death threats and and all
sorts of things um
but you can only you can only try and uh
try and be a good person and do things
the right way and as long as you're not
like there is some comedy too that like
there is [ __ ] that crosses the line i
don't think there's not i've said things
that have crossed the line i think
people should be allowed to do it but
there's definitely comedy with malicious
intent there is
sometimes you read a comment and you
made someone feel bad and you're not
like oh that's just a [ __ ] sometimes
you're like oh [ __ ] that actually feels
kind of shitty and i wasn't really
thinking about it that way and uh you
know that might i'm not gonna take it
down or alter my thing but you know
maybe
uh i'll keep that in mind for next time
right i feel like when i when i very
first started super young in comedy i
was nine i was in college i was 19 and i
think
what i like
not knowing how to write a joke or how
to get on stage and thank god i was in
some small town going on to some very
small like actual bar stage at the time
but
it was just like maybe i could just say
the most offensive thing i could think
of like not well not not the most
offense but like in at a certain extent
just like maybe you know what the punch
line is going to be is something that is
absurd to say in public because that's
how i knew to get a reaction out of
people and uh that's like what my
friends think is funny so you know
that's what i'll do now
yeah and that i think that's the thing
is like i think that's a natural stage
of comedy and and people shouldn't be
completely judged or raked over the
coals for that but there is also space
in society for saying like you tried
that and now you've realized yeah that's
the most defensive thing yeah and it's
the most offensive thing because it
offended people and maybe
maybe you will say maybe you'll say fine
i want to [ __ ] ride with that and
then that's your choice but sometimes
you go like okay
that was a little further than the line
that i like to be on you know
obviously there's a line right like
there's things
there's things in comedy specials from
the 80s that like no one like not even
the most
free speech uh warrior comic today would
say yeah yeah so
i think all of it gets a little bit
murky and and uh there doesn't seem to
be a lot of grace on the side of people
who want to cancel comedians but it also
sometimes the comedic argument can be a
little absurd uh
but it's just tough because everyone's
line is different right
yeah i think basically as long as it's
funny it's it plays like there's nothing
worse than an awkward silence after like
an edgy joke because then it's just like
like as long as it's actually funny it
plays i think yeah like any any comic uh
you go to an open mic and you see a
comic and they're like trying to be
jezelnik yeah but exactly they're just
not as but they're just not as good and
and of course they're not he's an
incredible joke writer like but it those
comics to get better they have to
wade through some insane [ __ ] to like
try and get to that point yeah
um
so you know i i will always def i will
always defend comics because i think
it's uh
it's it's important that we have our
like our right and our space to explore
[ __ ] that no one else is exploring
otherwise like all of society is just
boring um but like sometimes you're like
yeah it probably wasn't a great take or
joke and i'll defend your right to say
it but like you people are allowed to be
pissed as well yeah
awesome well this was a great
conversation really enjoyed talking to
you joey uh you want to plug any this
would come out uh the audio definitely
today the video i'm hoping by tonight
maybe tomorrow morning so uh any shows
podcasts socials whatever you want to
plug now
yeah absolutely um you mentioned it but
a bunch of my stuff's on instagram so
that's just at joey avery um joey avery
comedy on tick tock uh joey avery on
youtube i've got you know i've got tons
of stuff up there to watch right now and
then i do a podcast called pier 69 and
i'll be in austin next week
doing the chubbies comedy festival may
20th awesome well thank you again joey
and uh you know go check out his socials
and hopefully we'll hear from you again
soon all right thanks so much
[Music]
you